[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est le
général Vincent des portes merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes professeur de
stratégie ancien directeur de l'École de
guerre et auteur de ce livre qu'on va
voir devenez leader c'est aux édition
ODIL Jacob merci d'être notre invité ce
matin général on va évidemment parler
avec vous de ce conflit entre l'Israël
et le Hamas Israël qui a annoncé hier
avoir encerc
la ville de Gaza après une semaine de
combat au sol est-ce que ça signifie
qu'on va passer à une autre phase du
conflit ça signifie qu'on va passer à
une phase plus dure du conflit plus vous
vous rapprochez du cœur de des des des
ensembles militaires ou des des forces
plus ça vaê difficile il est clair que
plus tsal va avancer plus les combats
seront dur et plus les pertes seront
nombreuses des des deux côtés donc ça
veut dire qu'on c'est un conflit qui va
s'accroître en intensité pour vous ah
ben ben écoutez il va s'accroître à
intensité jusqu'au moment où il va
s'arrêter et ce qui peut le faire
s'arrêter c'est la pression
internationale peut-être en
parleraton jusqu'à ce que le le Israël
s'est donné comme mission de
détruire le Hamas et donc pour détruire
le Hamas il faudra beaucoup détruire à
côté il faudra aller dans les
sou-terrains ou détruire les
sou-terrains ce sera un affrontement au
corps à corps ce sera un affrontement
extrêmement sanglant et extrêmement
meurtrier et vous le dites il y a
beaucoup de souterrain beaucoup de
tunnels en quoi ça représente une
difficulté majeure pour t l'armée
israélienne et bien parce que le le
c'est le cœur de la force elle est pas à
l'extérieur elle est à l'intérieur et se
battre dans les tunnels représente une
difficulté majeure pourquoi parce que il
y a un pouvoir égalisateur de de des
tunnels c'estàdire que la l'armée
israélienne est une armée de haute
technologie mais cette haute technologie
en gros ne fonctionne pas ou n'apporte
rien dans les tunnels et donc on se
retrouve bien dans un combat domahom un
combat au poignard et et et et et au
réevolver si vous donc dégal à égal
entre le hamass et dégal à égal vous
êtes dans un tunnel c'est dégal égal là
c'est une affaire de courage et cetera
la la la deuxième chose c'est que les
tunnels donnent un avantage considérable
au Hamas c'est celui de la surprise on
voit les soldats du Hamas on les a vu
ressortir derrière les troupes de tsal
qui avaient avancé attaquer par derrière
et cetera donc quand on va s'attaquer au
tunnel on s'attaque au dur c'est pour ça
que les Israéliens Salal va chercher à
éviter la guerre des tunnels dans lequel
évidemment elle risque elle risque
beaucoup donc il y a des moyens
d'arrêter c'est de boucher les tunnels
c'est de les de les noyer et cetera mais
la difficulté c'est que avant de faire
ça il faudrait s'assurer qu'il n'y ait
pas d'otage dans ces tunnel or très
probablement le bien le plus précieux du
Hamas ce sont les otages qui sont mis en
lieu sû au fond des tunnels dans ces
tunnel çaut dire qu'on ne pourra pas que
ques ne pourra pas éviter cette guerre
des tunnels pour ah non il y a pas de il
y a non elle pourra pas elle elle elle
ne pourra pas et et c'est bien que c'est
ça est dans un piège ça elle savait
qu'elle tomberait dans un piège mais
elle est dans ce piège là qui qui va
devenir un bourbier sanglant bien sûr et
qui et qui est déjà on le sait une
triple catastrophe morale humanitaire et
stratégique mais est-ce que tsal avait
d'autres choix que cette stratégie là
il y a toujours est-ce que Benjamin
netanahou et maintenant son gouvernement
d'unau national avait avait un autre
choix bien sûr il y a toujours d'autres
choix que la guerre alors maintenant on
comprend très bien que Israël est choisi
de se lancer dans cette guerre- là tout
en sachant que c'était un piège qui lui
avait été tendu par le Hamas et très
probablement l'Iran et qu'elle accepit
de tomber dans ce piège là et qu'elle
considérait qu'elle qu'elle en sortirait
vainqueur ce qui hélas n'est pas dit il
y a il y a toujours d'autres solutions
que la guerre mais d'une part il y avait
une une volonté très humaine et
compréhensible évidemment de de de de de
vengeance disons-le et puis d'autre part
l'armée d'une part et netanahou d'autre
part avait quelque part le le la la la
nécessité de se racheter de l'échec
terrible du 7 octobre et ça ça ne
pouvait se faire que par la guerre on
rajoutera mais vous le savez bien que le
premier ministre netaniaou a des
intérêts personnels dans cette guerre
puisque d'une part il est quand même
coupable aux yeux de beaucoup d'avoir
laissé faire le 7 octobre et parce que
d'autre part pèse sur lui un certain
nombre d'inculpations judiciaaires et
que la seule façon de se sauver c'est de
gagner une bonne guerre donc il a et
mais c'est cette guerre est-ce que pour
être clair il y avait d'autres choix
qu'une opération terrestre est-ce que la
guerre elle était forcée de se mener de
cette manière-là par Benjamin netaniaou
non je crois pas il y avait il y avait
d'autres choix que cette opération
terrestre c'était très difficile de dire
ok nous sommes une grande nation nous
avons été frappés mais nous sommes
d'abord une démocratie et ce qu'il y a
au fond de la culture juive c'est le
refus de la violence et nous allons
faire autrement nous allons faire
autrement c'est-àdire essayer de il y a
eu une révolte du monde contre la
barbarie du 7 octobre et on voit bien
que l'onde de choc s'est retourné donc
il aurait été alors moi c'est facile de
le dire sur ce plateau de Public Sénat
mais il aurait été peut-être possible
de de de jouer sur l'émotion provoquée
par le 7 octobre pour arriver à à amener
les gouvernements arabe qui était dans
les accord d'Abraham ou pas comme
l'Arabie saoudite à trouver une solution
qui aurait enfin permis de de de bâtir
les fondements d'une paix future mais
c'était très compliqué puisque le les
les les suprémacistes israélien et NT en
particulier sont la seule solution c'est
les deux États mais dans le leur dans
leur programme de gouvernement et ben il
y a la la volonté de de ne pas avoir
deux états donc aller vers une solution
de paix c'était aller contre ce qui a
permis de créer la coalition au pouvoir
donc on voit que là aussi il y avait un
piège et que au fond ben la seule
solution possible c'était cette guerre
même si cette guerre est un piège dont
on ne sait pas comment Israël va
ressortir et Don dont on ne sait pas non
plus comment nous-mêmees occidentaux
allons ressortir parce que ce piège est
aussi le nôtre ouais on va en parler
mais pour pour ir sur la sur la
stratégie militaire vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la question des otages qui
évidemment sont une équation importante
dans cette guerre des tunnels est-ce que
comment on élabore une stratégie
militaire quand on sait qu'il y a des
otages écoutez c'est très compliqué je
sais pas comment on élabore ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'on voit ça change forcément
les choses ça change complètement les
choses ça change il y a deux choses il y
a deux éléments qui changent la donne un
les otages de la population Gazaoui qui
est qui qui est présente c'est bien pour
ça qu'Israël avait demandé
que la population Gazaoui quitte la zone
nord pour créer en quelque sorte une une
fre kill zone une zone dans lequelle
tout ce qui bouge et tu je me rappelle
qu'à un moment donné il a été dit après
ça a été retiré mais que toute tout
élément vivant non israélien dans le
nord de Gaza serait un ennemi donc on
pourrait tuer donc les deux éléments
mais qu' a refuser le Hamas est-ce que
pour le Hamas la population civile c'est
c'est un bouclier bah évidemment
évidemment c'est c'est les deux trésors
du Hamas c'est un les otages de la
population Gazaoui et je dirais que ça
marche bien ça marche bien puisque
Israël poursuit son affaire à tort ou à
raison et on on on a on a vu que les les
bombardements de j'oublie le nom de de
de ce camp de réfugiés sur lequelalia
Jabalia de Jabalia on on on voit bien
que c'est c'est c'est pas béni
évidemment pour le Hamas puisque c'est
un élément qui a encore plus retourneré
l'opinion publique contre Israël donc
donc c'est une erreur stratégique ça de
la part d'Israël la frappe de ce camp ah
moi je pense que c'est une faute oui je
je je pense que c'est c'est c'est je
pense que c'est une faute parce que
cette guerre d'Israël qui est légitime
dans ses
motivations pourrait devenir illégitime
par la façon dont elle est réalisée on
sait bien que en fait la légitimité
d'une guerre la légitimité lagalité
c'est chose mais la légitimité elle se
constate avant la guerre mais cette
légitimité est en permanence remise en
cause d'une part par la façon dont on
conduit la guerre et d'autre part par le
résultat de la guerre c'est-à-dire que
on sait qu'il y a le droit d'aller à la
guerre le youth adbum et le droit dans
la guerre le youth in below et on sait
qu'il a une interaction permanente et à
la fin une guerre est considérée comme
légitime si finalement on a respecter
une morale une éthique de la violence
dans son déroulement et si le résultat
est moral c'est pour ça qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que la guerre en Irak des
Américains en 2003 était illégitime
parce qu'elle a produit un résultat non
morale qui est la destruction du
Moyen-Orient qui a été daesh qui a été
le Bataclan et cetera de la même manière
la guerre lancée par la France et l'OTAN
en 2011 en Libye n'était pas légitime
parce qu'elle a produit à l'explosion du
Sahel à à l'arrivée des des des
djihadistes dans C dans cette zone les
les problèmes du Mali les problèmes du
Niger et cetera donc on voit bien que
quand je pars à la guerre je dois non
seulement la penser pour le résultat
immédiat mais je dois pens la pensere
surtout pour le coup d'après et c'est
bien ce qui semble manquer dans cette
affaire là on voit bien que la paix ne
se terminera que si les racines de la
violence seront exraes et donc la
question est quelles sont les quelles
sont les conditions que je dois créer
pour qu'enfin on sorte de ce conflit
permanent qui dure depuis
1947 entre les pays arabes puis la
Palestine et et Israël et pour vous ça
ça passe pas par l'éradication du Hamas
qui est l'objectif de Benyamine
néthanien oùou est-ce qu'il est tenable
alors moi je n'ai pas dit que ça ne
passait pas par l'éradication du Hamas
et je pense que le Hamas il doit
disparaître doit être détruit mais
faut-il le détruire par des moyens
militaires au risque de se voir
retourner complètement l'opinion
publique et au risque de voir Israël
finalement être tenu d'arrêter cette
guerre là de voir même ses alliés que va
faire aujourd'hui monsieur blinken à à
J à tavive mais juste est-ce que c'est
tenable l'objectif d'éradiquer le Hamas
alors attendez il faut savoir de quoi on
parle le Hamas est d'abord une idéologie
qui n'est pas que celle du Hamas parce
qu'elle est aussi celle de l'Iran et on
n'est pas très surpris qui est la
destruction d'Israël et donc tant qu'on
a'ura pas trouvé un moyen d'établir une
paix définitive cette idéologie
perdurera et donc ça vous ne pourrez pas
l'éliminer donc la réponse n'est pas que
militaire la réponse n'est pas que dans
dans ce que va faire Israël sur le
terrain depuis le début du monde la
guerre n'apporte jamais de solution à
quoi sert la guerre la guerre sert
toujours à changer les conditions
politiques d'où doit émerger une paix
meilleure que la précédente donc la
solution n'est jamais militaire la la
guerre est un moyen pour une fin et la
fin doit toujours être politique et il
n'y aura pas de paix au Moyen-Orient
tant qu'il n'y aura pas une perspective
de paix et de liberté pour le pour les
Palestiniens c'est comme ça et donc le
le le reproche qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui on sait pas tout ce qui se
passe mais cette guerre semble être
conduite par un souci de vengeance et on
le comprend bien mais surtout pour
elle-même or une stratégie ne fonctionne
que si elle vise un but positif et jbis
un but négatif là cette guerre elle veut
détruire une stratégie ne fonctionne que
si elle cherche à construire quelque
chose et si la destruction n'est jamais
qu'une marche pour aller vers cette
construction donc le but de guerre n'est
pas le bon le but de guerre n'est pas le
bon le but de guerre mais encore une
fois c'est compliqué puisque le le but
de guerre qui pourrait être le bon est
rejeté par la coédition de droite ou
suprémacie
aux affaires aux affaires en Israël donc
on voit bien que c'est c'est extrêmement
compliqué cette affaire là et qu'il est
important pour se faire que les amis
d'Israël dont nous sommes partis dont
les États-Unis font partie dont l'Europe
don l'Occident fait partie évidemment
conseil Israël a une retenue qui lui
permett d'arriver au résultat final
qu'on attend tous c'est-à-dire enfin le
règlement de ce
problème
israélopalestinien mais est-ce qu'Israël
les écoute parce que vous le dites
Anthony blinen le secrétaire d'État
américain est en Israël est-ce que les
Américains ont encore la main est-ce
qu'ils peuvent faire pression sur Israël
notamment pour qu'il n'aille pas trop
loin et pour protéger les civils
palestiniens bah écoutez oui vous avez
dit c'est exactement ce que va demander
monsieur blinken il il est il est clair
aujourd'hui si vous voulez que ne
serait-ce que pour que Israël puisse
continuer cette guerre il faut qu'Israël
fasse preuve d'humanisme à un moment
donné et dire nous ne sommes pas nous ne
sommes pas aussi barbares que les
barbares qui ont commis ces atrocités là
et pour là il faut être pour se faire il
faut être grand et donc à un moment
donné il il vaoir arriver à comprendre
ça moi je parle pas d'humanisme pour des
questions moral même si évidemment j'y
crois mais d'humanisme pour des
questions stratégiques et donc à des
moments donnés il faut faire des pauses
même si tactiquement c'est un peu
défavorable stratégiquement c'est
indispensable or on sait bien je
professeur de stratégie que la tactique
doit être subordonnée à la stratégie et
là on semble que il semble que ça n'est
pas le cas le problème le problème c'est
que nous sommes bien nous-mêmes Occident
dans ce piège pourquoi nous soutenons
Israël et nous avons raison de soutenir
Israël mais en même temps nous ne
pouvons pas contrôler ces agissements
donc quelque part nous Occident nous
sommes sponsors des des des des des
entorses parfois lourdes au droit de la
guerre que qu'a commis et que va
commettre Israël et quelle conséquence
ce piège pour les
occidentaux le piège le piège est clair
le piège c'est la le le rejet de
l'Occident un rejet de plus en plus
important de l'Occident parce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler le sud global déjà la
guerre en Ukraine avait enfoncé un coin
entre le entre l'Ouest et le Sud global
ou the West comme on peut l'appeler
également et ce coinl il est encore
enfoncé un peu plus par cette guerre là
nous avons nous Occident beaucoup
beaucoup à perdre nous sommes dans un
conflit qui n'est pas le nôtre parce que
nous n'avons pas les manettes on ne peut
rien faire mais nous en subirons des
conséquences alors on peut subir des
conséquences il y a aucun problème à
condition qu'à la fin le problème
israelllo-palestinien soit réglé parce
que tant qu'il sera pas réglé c'est une
bombe à retournement qui comme vous le
savez explose régulièrement et et qui et
qui déstabilise le monde et et et et qui
nous fait du mal regardez ce qui se
passe en France les actes les actes
antisémites ces comportements qui sont
absolument irresponsables nous sommes
concerné par ce conflit mais nous
n'avons pas les mains sur les manettes
vous vous parlez de la de la solution à
deux états aujourd'hui on est au tempant
des armes c'est les armes qui parlent
aujourd'hui est-ce que la solution à
deux états elle est viable et à quelle
échéance selon vous alors je suis désolé
mais je refuse l'expression nous sommes
autant des armes parce que je ne crois
pas à ça parce que je crois que il n'est
jamais trop tôt pour aller se projeter
au-delà non seulement il est jamais trop
tôt moralement mais il n'est jamais trop
tôt stratégiquement encore une fois mais
vous l'entendez Benjamin netano il veut
pas te cesser le feu mais mais mais je
je le comprends bien et c'est pour ça
que ses amis je suis pas un ami naniaou
mais les amis d'Israël et là j'en fais
partie doivent faire pression pour qu'on
subordonne les armes à la volonté
politique c'est absolument fondamental
évidemment moi je pense que la guerre si
elle continue comme elle a commencé elle
conduira peut-être à l'éradication des
gens qui s'appellent le Hamas maintenant
mais on aura un nouvelle amass qui va
arriver et cetera alors qu'il y a
évidemment des possibilités différentes
de de de terminer de terminer cette
affaire là à condition de bien
comprendre que le but ne doit pas être
élimination du Hamas c'est un but tout à
fait louable mais qui n'est jamais
qu'une étape dans la progression vers un
système de paix péren et là on en est
loin mais avec qui qui pour dialoguer
qui qui pour négocier ce ce système de
paix qui pour négocier alors il est
clair et là là il y a une faute du
gouvernement nataniaahou c'est que il y
a une autorité c'est l'autorité
palestinienne marbouabas mais on le sait
le le jeu depuis 15 ansin depuis 15 ans
a été de dévaloriser Mahmoud Abbas donc
l'Autorité palestinienne tout en faisant
monter le Hamas ce qui on le sait bien
il y a eu un jeu de du gouvernement
israélien de manière à ce que finalement
on étouffe on endorme le problème
palestinien et qu'il n'y ait plus de
revendication donc le problème
aujourd'hui c'est bien aussi de
retrouver une autorité politique
légitime qui viendra d'où je n'en sais
rien une autorité politique légitime qui
puisse reprendre le flambeau et
effectivement dialoguer alors c'est
compliqué parce que barbouabas est on le
dit à la télévision tous les jours
démonétisé et puis parce que il ne peut
pas revenir dans les fourgons de l'armée
israëline c'est pour ça que le problème
ne peut ne sera pas réglé si des pays
raisonnables qui sont les pays arabe
autour de ce problème je pense
évidemment à l'Égypte je pense à la
Jordanie je pense à l'Arabie Saoudite à
un moment dise ok on va on va trouver
une solution de toute façon admettons
que Israël s'empare de la bande de Gaza
bon je sais pas combien de temps ça peut
prendre un an un an et demi j'en sais
rien mais c'est possible pour vous mon
avis c'est pas c'est pas possible parce
que la la guerre va s'arrêter avant
parce que l'opinion internationale fera
s'arrêter cette guerre ou les Américains
diront bon c'est fini marre quoi bon il
en tient compte Benjamin netanahou de
l'opinion internationale ça a une
importance pour lui Ben pour l'instant
pas ce qui compte c'est sa survie
politique c'est ça qui est terrible si
vous voulez qu' y a une intrication des
intérêts personnels et des intérêts de
la nation B qui est intolérable et qui
et et et et et qui produit ça donc
reprenons l'hypothèse ok la guerre pas
la guerre est pas terminée mais le Hamas
est détruit qui va s'occuper de la bande
de Gaza qui va s'en occuper il faudra
bien quelqu'un est-ce que ça peut-être
l'armée israélienne non elle a déjà
essayé en 2005 elle est parti et puis
maintenant on a un peu de recul est-ce
que l'armée américaine est arrivé à
gérer parce que c'était bien ça
l'Afghanistan est-ce que l'armée
américaine est arrivée à régler le
problème iraakien restant sur zone non
au fond les militaires sont pas faits
pour ça parce que c'est pas leur vrai
métier donc Israël ne saura pas faire
Israël ne saura pas faire donc il faut
bien une autorité non militaire qui s'en
occupe est-ce que l'ONU fera je sais pas
l'ONU est complètement démonétisé est-ce
que Israël supportera que l'ONU rentre
dans dans cette affaire là c'est pas
absolument évident donc il faut arriver
à trouver une autorit qui alors est-ce
que les Américains sont en mesure
d'imposer à Israël une solution
politique mais les les on n'impose plus
de solution politique aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça la puissance est est
dévalorisée et gel parlait de
l'impuissance de la victoire he de
siècles plus de siècles et demi et il
parle de ça c'estdire que la victoire
non pardon un siècle et demi la la la
victoire elle-même ne est impuissante et
l'Amérique est impuissante si elle avait
été si puissante que ça politiquement
l'Amérique elle serait sorti sortie
victorieuse de la guerre en Irak ou de
la guerre en Afghanistan dont elle est
sortie perdante donc on voit bien que la
solution politique aujourd'hui elle
repose sur un consensus sur un dialogue
et qu'on imposera pas il faudra bien que
ce soit une solution qui soit trouvée
par les pays arabes qui redeviendront
raisonnables et qui diront il faut
sortir de cette affaire- là on peut pas
aller vers un affrontement frontal entre
l'Occident et le reste un mot sur le le
risque d'extension du conflit
puisque'hier le Hezbollah a mené des
attaque simultané sur 19 positions
israéliennes est-ce que ça veut dire que
le hzbolah s'apprête à entrer en guerre
écoutez on le sera tout à l'heure le le
le le chef du du
du le chef dub doit prendre la parole
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre de ce
discours qu'est-ce qu'on peut craindre
de ce discours à mon avis ce ce sera un
discours mitigé il va pas dire
brutalement je déclare la guerre à
Israël parce qu'il meurt dans dans les 5
minutes il sera bombarder Israël s'est
très bien ce monsieur donc il va mourir
dans 5 minutes donc évidemment ce sera
pas ce sera ce sera pas comme ça ce sera
peut-être une étape mais on attend
toujours beaucoup de choses de ces
grands discours il va il va pas se
passer grand-chose il va menacer Israël
il va dire c'est pas bien et cetera mais
évidemment il va pas dire je je rentre
en guerre et d'autre part il a pas
vraiment intérêt mais il est pas mal le
hzbollah au Liban en fait il a une armée
qui est supérieure à l'armée à l'armée
libanaise finalement c'est lui qui tire
les ficelles il y a quand même une ronde
de situation l'entrée en guerre serait
la fin de cette R de situation mais vous
avez raison à côté de ça la raison
d'être du hzbollah c'est le combat comme
Israël et donc en fait il va dans son
discours essayer de rétablir un
équilibre dans cette dialectique entre
le besoin de préserver sa position et le
besoin de de justifier l'existence même
du hbola mais pour vous il niront pas
jusqu' entr en guerre non ils iront
peut-être mais ils vont pas le dire là
ils vont pas le dire là parce que Israël
figurez-vous qu'Israël attend aussi ce
discours là et il y a je sais pas
combien de roquettes qui sont prêts à
s'abattre dans la secondde sur les les
positions dub qui sont connus parce
qu'ils sont pas dans les souterrains ils
sont à l'extérieur et sur le rôle de
l'Iran le rôle de l'Iran évidemment dans
cette affaire là fondamentale on ne sait
pas à quel point l'Iran a commandité
organisé soutenu la masse du 7 octobre
la l'attaque terrible mais il est
évident qu'il y a un lien très fort on
sait bien que le la volonté de l'Iran
est également la destruction d'Israël
mais que l'Iran n'est pas suffisamment
fort pour aller attaquer frontalement
Israël et que donc c'est pour ça que
l'Iran a constitué ce qu'il appelle un
axe de la résistance et au fond domine
quatre États arabes le le Yémen l'Irak
la Syrie et et le Liban et donc on a une
guerre asymétrique ou dissymétrique qui
est conduite mais toutes ces affair là
évidemment arrange le pouvoir en Iran
qui préfère voir la rue de téran hurler
à mort Israël plutôt que liberté pour
les femmes le pouvoir des hayatollah est
aujourd'hui un pouvoir qui est affaibli
d'une part et d'autre part tant que le
conflit
israélo-palestinien existe ça renforce
la position dans le monde arabe
puisqu'on sait bien qui que l'Iran
détient une partie des clés de cette
affaire- là donc l'Iran a intérêt à
avoir une une chaudière qui bouillonne
en permanence que le feu ne soit jamais
éteint ça lui donne de la force ça lui
donne une légitimité et ça lui permet
d'asseoir son pouvoir répressif sur sa
population merci général vandpte merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on revoit
votre livre devenez leader cette édition
jaob merci infiniment d'avoir été notre
invité on passe au club des territoires